this movie so silly the transporter
refueled there's a transporter refueled
as a new transporter movie it's
ultimately a reboot of the transporter
franchise so the transporter is doing
his transporter thing kind of at the
very beginning it was kind of cool like
these guys trying to mug him he kicks
their ass you like seeing that he's
badass and he gets a client it's like
hey the car go it's us three women so it
transport us I guess he has to take on
this Russian [ __ ] who's trafficking
women that's pretty much the movie
sounding interesting seriously Smoove II
had a lot of problems and it was
apparent right out the gate right off
the bat this movie was going to be a
mess because the first thing that
happens it's like a bunch of people
these guys get out of their cars wipe
them all out and this guy's like I
didn't [ __ ] snow that's my shitty
Russian accent Russians were really hard
accent to do there's like ladies get to
work start like banging dudes no
wouldn't cleaned up the body so you know
what would kill my boners if I'm out
they're scoping for some ass on my oh
hey oh my god look at all those bodies
umm just not in the mood anymore back
your boss is an idiot for not thinking
of that vibe then the movie jumps 15
years later and you see the crew that
wiped everyone out and it has to show
that they were the crew it shows this
guy and then it flashes back to him
wiping everyone out 15 years ago and it
shows the other guy into shows him it's
like I imagine they would have been the
people who did this and you wouldn't
have had to do those jarring stupid
flashbacks in this scene if you picked
people who are memorable things happen
in this movie but you're always waiting
for it to become interesting it's proof
that just because a movie is moving
along does not mean it's moving along
interestingly even the father dynamic in
this movie Ray Stevenson plays his
father for some one reason I didn't like
them as father and son because it has
his shoved down your throat why the
transporter has his rules that he has
you know he's like oh I'm gonna be late
my father hates it when I'm late his
dad's like you're late Junior I'm 30
seconds late that's too late sir like oh
that's why the transporter is all about
his schedule is all about being on time
I would have thought if I had to make a
story for the transporters family life I
would have made his father some burnout
with no schedule whatsoever who always
disappointed him and let him down and
that's why he's actually so OCD about
being on time and schedules and that's
why he wants to be successful despite
the clients he takes on because he
doesn't want to end up like his dad I
would just been more interesting but
ultimately this guy's a likable guy all
right
why are you in the line of work you're
in I saw no reason in this movie why the
transporter should want to take on this
career and the movie tries to do that
Jackie Chan thing that we all love you
know you watch rumble in the Bronx I
love how Jackie Chan takes refrigerators
it opens the doors beats people down
uses his environment as weapons this
movies like we're gonna do that too and
it's [ __ ] double the fights in this
movie man I was like I don't get with a
returnee there's just one fight where
the transporters taken on a couple of
guys down this super narrow hallway and
it is awkward looking he keeps opening
these drawers to hit these guys the
drawers are all kanpai it just looks
messy it looks sloppy maybe that's what
the drawers would do doesn't change the
fact you're like this looks like garbage
I shouldn't have fought down this narrow
ass hallway of all the fights you could
have done in the locations you could
have done them in with the settings you
could have had you picked this mess guys
in the end I don't know what the
transporter was trying to do but it
didn't do it it tried to be exciting it
didn't do that
the father-son dynamic in this movie was
an okay one if it wasn't in a
transporter movie the villain was [ __ ]
no one's memorable the movie is easy as
hell Dannette pick from the fact that
everyone growls when they talk to kill
you if I kill you first all the way to
the fact this girl gets shot in the very
next scene she's having a threesome I
should have been let alone through some
knee but the whole time I'm going didn't
you just get shot I'm so glad that you
could do a threesome right after you
take a bullet in your side I had a
really shoddy stitch job to fix it that
this movie that's this movie guys in the
end the transporter refueled is boring a
[ __ ] and is in fact dog [ __ ] all right
so transporter we filled have you seen
it what did you think about I'm not
gonna lie it's all this yesterday I was
like have you decided interview movies I
don't like whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you